una gigante obra en construcción en una
de las zonas más deprimidas al norte de
París poco a poco va tomando forma la
Villa Olímpica abarca un total de 52
hectáreas el equivalente a 70 canchas de
fútbol en el verano de 2024 llegarán los
primeros habitantes 14.000 atletas y sus
acompañantes se instalarán en
apartamentos de habitaciones de 9 a 13
metros cuadrados
Allison pino campeona olímpica de
balonmano descubre la que podría ser su
casa en menos de 500 días
en una Villa hay mucha convivencia es
muy amigable es la oportunidad de
conocer súper estrellas que uno ve en
televisión y atletas de naciones más
pequeñas que solo envían un puñado de
deportistas a competir en 2019 se puso
la primera piedra desde entonces un
ballet incesante de 3.500 obreros
trabaja casi contrarreloj pues los
diferentes crisis internacionales han
afectado el cronograma de las obras los
encargados de las infraestructuras
olímpicas y paralímpicas han sudado frío
nos topamos con el covid luego la guerra
en Ucrania el covid en China Todos hemos
trabajado juntos para superar la crisis
para encontrar las soluciones frente al
desabastecimiento de materiales de
Ucrania para seguir trabajando durante
la pandemia a pesar de que china cerró
sus fronteras
tras las justas de verano de la Villa
Olímpica nacerá un nuevo barrio para
seis mil habitantes con comercios
escuelas y un 25% de viviendas de
interés social el costo total de la obra
3.500 millones de euros después de los
juegos habrá unas 2000 viviendas miles
de metros cuadrados de oficinas
servicios y espacios públicos a
disposición y almacenes va a ser un
nuevo barrio adaptado al futuro el
resultado será la prueba de que hemos
logrado todos nuestros objetivos Esta
obra colosal debe ser ya entregada a
finales de este año 2023 y luego a
principios de marzo de 2024 será la
organización de los Juegos Olímpicos la
que ya quede a cargo de todo este lugar
pero la aspiración a largo plazo es la
de transformar la vida no solamente de
la gente de todo este nuevo barrio sino
también el departamento más pobre de
toda Francia Metropolitana